- That's one of my very
favorite parts of Instagram
is just writing really stupid things.
Sometimes I write things
just to make people
choke on their coffee.
(upbeat music)
- Hi, I'm Jihan Zencirli.
Welcome to my studio.
I own Geronimo Balloons
in Echo Park, California.
I am Geronimo, Geronimo is me.
It's an extension of whatever
I'm interested day to day.
I've always made things
as a way, as an outlet.
My first balloon I ever gave
was for my best friend's
birthday about six years ago.
I showed up to the restaurant
and I had a big balloon inflated
and people at the
restaurant just went wild.
(upbeat music)
we do really crazy stuff.
Any day or week could be different.
We create backdrops for
photo shoots, for TV.
We do parties, we do events,
we do branding for companies.
When someone has like an idea or a need,
we come in and we just are like
come up with the craziest idea
and hope that they say yes.
When Kanye West wanted to have
a ceiling full of balloons,
we made it for him,
for like a secret concert
that he was having.
I love Instagram
and I love engaging with
people through Instagram.
I love watching what other people
are doing through Instagram.
You want a place to kind of
see if people are interested
in the things you're doing.
So, Instagram immediately was a place
that I could try out
new colors, new ideas.
We had a huge burst of people
when one of the Kardashians
had a birthday party
and included us in her round
of the favorite things.
So, in the night,
I think we had like
10,000 extra followers,
which shows the power of Instagram.
When I think of what I want to be able
to achieve as an artist,
it's really not about the visual product.
It's about this feeling or
this movement, this idea,
this place that I can create for people,
which is wonder.
I think, as adults,
it's really hard to like
find wonder in things
because we've seen it all,
we've experienced it all.
A little piece of wonder
is what I want my legacy to be
or what I want my art to be
because it just makes people happy.
It does.
I see it and that is so fulfilling to me.
(upbeat music)